Pendleton two to five yogurt the teams
are combining for under nineteen percent
shooting in there to throw away
Oman us into the crowd spilled the beer
[Applause]
some slits maybe who knows he's just
soaked in beer and the part that's in
the guys here it's in the guys here your
blood so about three no be Ridge
everyplace some of Milwaukee's the
Miller highlight spilled on the floor
don't think of any more beers oh you are
on a right to tell Kylie with a mess you
have decompressed in the church then
Caicos you are on fire my friend
alright the clock was screwed up and
then somebody spilt something on the
floor all they ask you to do courtside
is hold on dear drink and don't spill on
the floor and we know it wasn't a drink
it was beer took hold on to you beer
water wasn't speeding in fear like was
it three two cores or was it like like
with secular corn since when Denver it's
got to be course why exactly or some
other ones we're gonna get in trouble
now with all the craft beer breweries
that children they're inbound pardon
trying to get trimmed down to three down
two turret approve
good
James Harden up 20 before incredible
shot rockets by one with one second to
go do some kind of tenure but get the
food if they had 102 at the must be
right three chapters are hamburgers and
popsicles or something I figure it was
three zero if it's three food you would
go free chip for a sandwich
[Laughter]
oh I think it's I think if you missed
two free throws off of Mills and off the
Spurs and ten seconds on the shot clock
with the FinCEN if we don't think no
they'd know every free food free food by
get free t-shirts during the game three
anything they get excited rehab tonight
[Applause]
[Laughter]
the chick-fil-a cow church
[Applause]
[Music]
Dallas it's got the lead
[Applause]
what did we just see what a play by
DeRozan Baryshnikov I don't bring you to
your seat there was an Alexander one
that crazy phone button that beautiful
now hard for the NBA on TNT is brought
to you by Burger King try the six dollar
King box including one classic entree
fries a drink in two cookies
[Applause]
[Music]
oh there's a [ __ ] to the chicken coop
[Applause]
the Gucci Mane is here the celtics there
you go you know what I was gonna wear
that tonight and all that bling I was
gonna wear it tonight but I thought I'd
give it to him no another another clock
issue you call gucci mane I know him by
his real name Radek
Delana davis you were you're in the know
you are in the know my friend yep well
it's just my goodbye a minute a half ago
let the talk-radio start right now come
on man right now we're goin the Browns
gone no double double they're not
talking about anything out burgers I
could take yo couch
[Applause]
Jennifer
[Applause]